amerimike Islamic Adam is completely in
his element
serving cappuccinos to the guests in
this cafe waiting tables is his first
ever job and the 40 year old is loving
every second of it I like the cafe it's
big and it's nice and warm that's why
I'm so grateful to the owner mrs. Eiger
he every night when I go to bed I thank
her he and the others who work here have
little chance of finding work elsewhere
Iran's job market is currently in such a
bad state that over a third of
college-educated young Iranians are
unemployed for people with special needs
it's become nearly impossible to find
work for most of those people there's
nothing to do once they finish school
they just stay at home
but we're convinced it's good for them
to show people that they have other
abilities not just good for them it's
also good for their families they're
often sad because they can't do anything
but here they can show just what they're
capable of more than 40 people living
with Down syndrome or autism work here
regulary everybody pitches in doing what
they can
brewing coffee waiting tables or
entertaining the guests with music
they all get paid for their work except
for the cafe owner alina ngahi she runs
a deficit every month there are very few
government programs to support social
projects like this one in the islamic
republic we've never received support
from any kind of organization it's a
completely independent project founded
and financed privately
we're totally self dependent giving up
it's not an option because every day she
sees just how much this work means to
Imran and the others I used to just be
with my father but now he's dead
but father look at me now I finally made
it I'm famous and go through life with
my head raised high see with their
positive attitude Imran and his
colleagues have created an atmosphere
found nowhere else in the Islamic
Republic
no other cafe here in Iran could get
away with this level of frivolity Imran
and the others are making the best out
being a little bit different and have
transformed confident ISM into a place
that's bursting with positivity